We're losing people because of the fear of
this building.
There is something in that basement.
It's affected my family, my relationship,
my career.
These things are real.
Who believes this place is haunted?
Are you human?
I hear gay people.
Remember in high school I didn't know which
one I was more afraid of, telling people I
was gay or telling them I saw ghosts.
Velvet! There's a woman in a mansion with
problems.
We're not supposed to feel alone.
You need to know these things are not
permanent.
I very strongly connect with those that have departed.
I am the resident, which depending on how the
shells fall, that's how I interpret what the
message is.
I think we should use the SLS.
Oh my God.
Okay, there's someone sitting in the chair.
Based on these cards, I do believe you're in
danger, girl.
Now, when a Latina has this much eyeliner on,
she means business.
What'd you just say?
What'd you just say? Tell me.
It's actually a demonic entity.
What are we going to do?
Somebody with a flashlight go ahead of me.
He ain't gonna let you rain on my parade no
more.
The demons we sometimes deal with that are
the hardest are those we find within ourselves.
I'm so proud of you and I see you.
If me dealing with the world keeps me from
dealing with me on my worst day, I'm okay
with that.
I won't leave with that being the truth.
It's time to let go of this.
I just want you to know you made it through
it and you came out stronger.
I want to empower the good spirits.
Who's ready to get freaky?
Take our hands as we criss-cross America through the unknown
and beyond.
We're living for the dead.